do intel's new alder lake performance
laptop chips put apple's new m2s to
shame well let's take a look we have
benchmark numbers from the m2 and then a
lot of laptops coming out with these new
chips that are extremely impressive
let's see how they stack up both with
the cpu performance the graphics
performance battery life and talk about
unplugged performance let's start out by
taking a look at the m2 just showing you
how much faster it is compared to the m1
because it's actually a more impressive
update than we expected starting out
with single core performance we have a
nice jump up to
1919 now this processor the m2 uses the
same 15 watts of power but apple is
actually able to raise up the frequency
up to 3.5 gigahertz from 3.2 now as far
as multi-core we have a jump of 19 and a
half percent
faster with the same wattage that is
pretty dang impressive but we'll see how
it compares to intel's now 400 cpu load
in cinebench r23 we had some numbers
came out uh but they seem a little bit
off so running just what apple told us
as far as performance the single core
should be up to 1800 which is really
good and the multi-core up to 9000 300
or so now on the graphic side this is
where things got very impressive we are
seeing a score of 30
600
that is extremely impressive almost 45
increase in performance now if we add in
the m1 pro from the 2 000 14 inch
macbook pro you'll see that the m2 is
much closer to that 14 core chip than it
is to the acor m1 now that chip actually
uses about 25 watts of power or so
compared to 15 watts for the m2 now this
has me wondering did apple upgrade the
fan and the 13 inch macbook pro to work
better and to be able to handle this
higher wattage because that 14 inch has
dual fans in there that are keeping it
cool with that higher wattage was still
not bad because that chassis actually
goes up to m1 max but anyways if we jump
to real world gaming performance with
gfx bench we are seeing over a 45 jump
in performance uh that is great now
switching over to the higher resolution
off-screen test we have a really nice
gain performance and adding in the m1
pro you see how the m2 scales now if we
actually take that fps when we break it
down to fps per core the m2 is the most
impressive at 11 fps per core compared
to 9.7 with the m1 but it uses the same
amount of wattage one and a half watts
per core compared to the m1 pro which
actually uses more power so there you
guys go you see how the m2 compares to
the m1 and the m1 pro it is very
impressive both with the performance
gains and the amount of power that it
uses now let's bring in intel's crazy
1280p
which is a crazy chip it uses a base of
28 watts which is almost double apple's
m2 chip at 15 watts but not only that it
actually can use up to 65 watts if you
have the thermal performance and will
actually reach 80 watts if it's unlocked
in a crazy laptop chip now the new xps
13 plus has this available and we do
have one that we're gonna get in and do
a full hands-on comparison like we've
done before comparing everything about
these systems including uh the
performance when you unplug it so if you
guys want to see that make sure you guys
click that subscribe button below and
with that you will help us reach our
goal of 1 million subscribers now this
new 14 core laptop from intel is
expensive if you get it in xps you're
spending about two thousand dollars so
it's actually not competing with the m2
macbook pro but in fact the 14 inch m1
pro instead now you can also get the 12
core i5 version which is right in line
with the m2 macbook pro in terms of
pricing so i'm going to give performance
to both of these really nice new chips
compared to the m2 to show you how good
these new intel chips are look at how
they compare to the previous best i7
laptop chip even the new i5 is way
faster and then the new i7 14 core
version is more than twice as fast
and they actually throttle less in this
new xps now comparing it to apple's m2
we're gonna start off with single core
here and the i7 beats out the m1 but it
does not match the new m2 which is the
fastest laptop chip in terms of single
core performance in multi-core the m2
beats out the price competitive i5 but
the i7 version beats out the m2 by about
10
in the xps 13. now personally i am very
curious about how these new 12 core and
14 core chips will perform on battery
power because nobody has tested it out
yet we know that the 11 gen tiger lake
cpus in xps 13 would slow down quite a
bit when you unplug them and these are
way more powerful so it is possible that
these will be limited somewhere between
28 to 35 watts when you're on battery
power instead of running at around 50 to
60 watts when you have them plugged in
but of course we'll find out as soon as
we get them in now as far as graphics
these new chips unfortunately are not
much faster than before because the
graphics they're based on the same gpu
design in terms of raw performance we
are seeing 1.6 teraflops for the i5 and
2.2 teraflops for the i7 which means
that even the m1 beats out the new i7
best intel laptop chip and then the m2
definitely smokes it as far as geekbench
compute testing the best intel processor
using vulkan scores just under the m1
while the m2 graphics are more than
twice as fast as a similarly priced i7
and about 50 faster than the i7 chip
which is priced about the same as a 14
inch m1 pro macbook pro so it looks like
in terms of gpu compute performance
these latest intel chips cannot really
compete with apple's graphics which is
probably why so many reviewers didn't
really touch on graphics performance
they focused on the cpu now we also know
that these graphics which are similar to
the last generation did not perform the
same as with geekbench tests which have
a bunch of different things put together
when we took a look at photo and video
editing they actually were quite a bit
slower than what the benchmarks would
show you as far as gaming the 1440p
manhattan off-screen test shows just how
fast the m2 is compared to the i7 even
the m1 is close to twice as fast but the
m2 is up to 2.4 times faster than the i7
and then adding in the m1 pro which is
similarly priced that is almost 3.5
times faster but of course even though
we have this great gaming performance
for metal optimized games we don't have
a lot of those those games are on
windows but this laptop still isn't
going to do a good job playing them you
will have to pick up a thicker heavier
larger laptop that has dedicated nvidia
graphics built into it but then we also
know that when you have that graphics
card you have to keep it plugged in
because when you unplug it the gaming
performance with the nvidia chips
plummets now as far as the battery life
for real world mix tasks this isn't just
simple you know video playback with low
brightness the i5 with the 1080p screen
doesn't do so bad but the i7 with the
3.5 key screen is still pretty terrible
like it was before and we don't know
what kind of performance loss we're
gonna get when you unplug it from the
wall we'll have to see now the m1 and
the m2 macbook pros have really clear
battery life and of course the
performance does not change it is
consistent so with that said do intel's
latest alder lake 12 core and 14 core
processors destroy the m2 well kind of
but not exactly first off if we're
looking at the i5 version it is much
closer to the m2 in some cases a little
bit faster but most cases it is not
now a lot of the headlines that people
are talking about they're comparing to
the i7 which is a much more expensive
chip and it doesn't really compete with
the m2 it's not in that price range now
along with that what a lot of other
articles and videos aren't talking about
are the graphics performance i know
linus kind of just skimmed over that
section completely in their long video
so graphics performance it also does not
compete and then if you're adding extra
graphics like nvidia well you're in a
different category as far as size and
price as well now it is very impressive
what kind of performance they're able to
get out of the chip especially if they
put it in thicker laptops and run the
cpu closer to 65 or even up to 80 watts
it is killer and intel is doing a great
job but of course you have that the
balance of battery life performance and
everything else that the laptops offer
now i'm glad that we have competition
i'm glad that intel is stepping up it is
great to push the whole industry forward
but you guys let me know what you guys
think down below check out one of those
great videos right over there click
above to subscribe if you guys want to
help us reach your goal of one million
subscribers this has been max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]